and now it's time for that cartoon show
with cartoons you died laughing at the
smash hit comedy of the year The
Hangover well now because Hollywood is a
bunch of money-grubbing whores we're
proud to present the sequel The Hangover
2 starring Kanye West and Congressman
Joe Wilson nah man what happened I don't
know
last thing I remember we had 12 bacon
vodka martinis and the rest is kind of a
blur well let's check the TV and see if
we missed anything today in the news
Kanye was made a complete ass of himself
last night grabbing the mic away from
MTV Award winner Taylor Swift Beyonce is
the best bitch you suck balls
nope well that's what happens when
pretentious rapper can hold his liquor
you gotta be like me kid totally in
control no matter what the situation is
people are still talking about
Congressman Joe Wilson outburst during
Obama's last speech maybe it's because
you too busy being totally in control
jerk off with Serena Williams they say
anything about me
what the hell cares nobody watches
tennis and in Sports News everybody's
watching tennis to see if Serena
Williams will have yet another outburst
at one of the officials for its fault oh
my friends I guess the three of us have
a lot of bad behavior to explain hey
wait a minute
wait there for this oh god where's Paula
yeah I'll leave American Idol hmm yeah
because the money I just don't have
enough money goddamn much that's the
hangover - I'm really sorry Nina I
completely botched up milah hope is that
the fans and the American people can
forgive me for all the pain that I've
caused all right well why don't you
think about how you're an unapologetic
badass now okey
I apologize from the bottom of my heart
and I feel really bad about what I did
you long I'll shop it's great to be
hosting Saturday Night Live where any
celebrity can win the American people
back by simply mocking the incredibly
stupid things that they've done okay who
is that oh well let's see what I did
this time hopefully it wasn't too
embarrassing all I do is dropped
American Idol has now been replaced with
Ellen DeGeneres oh and I still drunk I
think I'm still drunk oh you still drunk
but everything the TV just say was real
coming soon to a theater near you